that's a unique looking burger
cabio black truffle agra oh my god
i don't think we should ever serve this
that is the craziest thing i've ever
seen
i'm calling this a baseball burger i'm
stuffing it
with american cheese you're wrapping it
like a baseball
yeah basting it in butter i feel like
this is kind of like the secret to this
getting that like nice caramelization
down grilled cheese top and bottom
you're taking two sort of beloved
concepts and mashing them together
are um cheese on the burger too yes sir
[ __ ] eh
that's it that's the burger
this is nuts look at that this is nuts
perfect example of [ __ ] instagram
food
two bites and you're out i feel kind of
gross
i enjoyed it i am like into it
i kind of want them to package this up
and i'll take it home on to the next
burger
[Music]
it's a founded burger i invented it the
process
is very simple we are taking a burger
and then we are putting it inside a
tortilla
pressure machine and then we are
roasting it on the plunge
adding the cheddar cheese and folding
because we want to create a kind of pie
that when
we should put it inside the pita all the
steam
will go direct into your nose when you
are eating it
one of the most amazing burgers this is
so good i've ever had in my life
i'm not even i'm not oh my i love you
okay i love you you need people oh this
might just be what i've been looking for
my whole life
let's make the world spiciest hamburger
the burner burger what i have is salt
mix of chili powder
chili oil
we have a blend of ghost pepper trinette
scorpion
two types of habanero uh carolina reaper
dripping a little bit of that oh my god
so on a scoville scale this is gonna be
roughly two million you can even rub it
in the side of that
i'm not doing that okay cheers
i'll see you on the toilet later
[Music]
what do you guys think what's going on
what's happening
i think we did it
i do want another bite yeah but i feel
like i can't i feel like i just gave
satan a
deep throat blow job yeah i do feel that
the 777 burger from the burger brossery
this is a surf and turf burger what are
you thinking first things first
look like it's some [ __ ] that's still
moving on here
how much is this burger it's a 77 burger
but if you want it for 777 dollars you
get
dom p rose
kobe beef patty it's broiled on the
grill topped with goat cheese
caramelized onions pancetta foie gras
arugula lobster and drizzled with a
hundred year old
aged balsamic but what's this foie gras
that's
a duck liver it's super rich it's
balling
it honestly it just tastes like fat yeah
i know that
okay you give it give just a just a just
a little bit
i thought it was a mushroom i feel like
dave chappelle
yeah y'all i got dinosaur eggs in my
refrigerator
[ __ ] i'm bawling
[Music]
what are you tasting like i don't taste
the bacon
i don't i for sure don't taste the
lobster me neither but at the end of the
day
if i'm gonna pay 77 for a burger
i want that burger to slap me in the
face the bread good though
[Music]
this is the connecticut steamed
cheeseburger right it exists
only within about a seven mile radius of
the geographic center of connecticut
well what are we doing so there's a
reservoir on the bottom which is boiling
water okay
right and then on the inside we have we
have shelves
the trays go in here they slide in and
they cook the meat and the cheese
separately it's a very odd way to make a
burger obviously
you're packing these into a burger what
do we do it's a bigger mold right it's
weird
but we're not actually making a bowl of
the burger we're putting the mold itself
into the seamer
oh look at that hot steam here the beef
goes in pop it in
the cheese goes in we close it up it
comes out and goes in a bun
so i'm gonna do this it comes out of
here look at that goes on there it's the
crazy part right here
yeah this is this is the magic right
here there's the magic right here yeah
this is the oh yeah baby
and that is a steam cheeseburger that is
the craziest thing i've ever seen
oh no cheese is dope oh
that's the star yeah
sorry i'm just getting really emotional
right now
[Music]
it's a [ __ ] good burger man
[Music]
so goodbye go get
the camera away from me i'm serious